Tom fought the scariest dude in the
division Sergey pavich and he did an
interview with Seno and in this
interview he revealed that he had a back
injury and didn't train over a week
before the fight so the fight was on a
two week notice so he trained exactly
sevenish days maybe less than that and
became world champion and not only did
he beat Serge he beat him at his own
game he knocked him out in under 990
seconds how weird was it when they're
doing the face off there inside the they
put their hands on each other I was like
oh that's interesting they're both like
congrats man Tommy's biggest ass said he
he's just faster than everybody
including suron including Jon Jones
including Stipe he's just faster than
everybody in the world you know bisbing
was the first to do this again on a
two-e notice when he became world
champion the first English Champion now
Tom asol carries that Throne Tom Asal is
hands down your world heavyweight
champion Undisputed